don't worry i'll guide you through it  it's just like riding a hoverbike  you guys have hoverbikes  [Music]  these train things that that's magnetic  levitation right  obviously obviously but i've never seen  it this  efficient  [Music]  here are your communication devices for  career  unlimited range also equipped with audio  surveillance system  check these out remote  access kimoyo beans  [Music]  fully automated like the old american  movie baba used to watch  and i made them completely sound  absorbent  [Music]  interesting  delete that footage  [Music]  remote piloting system activated  oh my god  [Music]  remote driving system activated  the entire suit sits within the teeth of  the necklace  let's go  [Music]  you